welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and stranger
things is back baby at first i was like
it's gonna take me how long to watch
this but 15 minutes into the first
episode i knew that seven episodes
wasn't nearly enough i loved this season
even though i think it's really rude of
netflix to make us wait for the finale
so in the meantime i'm gonna break down
all the details you might have missed in
stranger things four volume one on to
the upside down chapter one the hellfire
club opens in a quiet neighborhood in
hawkins indiana where the local paperboy
from the hawkins post is delivering
newspapers this is the same newspaper
that nancy and jonathan were fired from
in season three thanks to the influence
of the mind flare at one house a man
opens the door for the paper and through
a series of close-up shots we learn that
this is dr brenner he fills out a
crossword in 10 minutes and most of the
words are pretty standard crossword fare
but i find it particularly interesting
that a shot centers on the word
ideological which means serving to
explain something by giving the cause or
reason for it this is a subtle clue
about brenner's role this season as his
plotline centers around the origin of
both 11 and the new bbeg from the upside
down this very opening itself is a part
of this ideological tale as it takes
place on september 8 1979 the day an
eight-year-old 11 would find herself at
the center of a bloodbath in hawkins
national laboratory if you look closely
you can see a slight tear to the upside
down a hint to the full story revealed
in episode 7. we flash forward to march
of 1986 six months and apparently
several character growth spurts after
the battle of star court in season three
the mamas in the papa's california dream
and plays as we enter 11's room dora
left open with a three-inch minimum just
like she promised hop in season three
elle looks like a mini clone of joyce
who is now working as a telemarketer for
encyclopedia britannica jonathan is a
big old stoner with a best friend named
argyle when we catch up with will he's
getting his picasso on and a boys don't
cry cure poster hangs in his studio
moments later we see will carrying an
alan turing poster for a school project
alan turing was a mathematician and
considered the father of artificial
intelligence technology turing was
persecuted for being gay in the 1950s so
this seems to be another nod that will
is a friend of dorothy which has been
hinted at throughout the series back in
hawkins the party has joined a new dnd
group called the hellfire club a
reference to the elite secret society
that often came into conflict with the
x-men in marvel comics the hellfire club
is dm'd by eddie munson a metal punk
seeker of darkness who is not like the
other warlocks and introduces his
bandmates from corroded corpse dustin
mike and lucas sometimes this year lucas
is double timing their cult of wechna
campaign with the tigers basketball team
and from the moment team captain jason
drags up the names of the recently
deceased for a pep rally chant you just
know that this is a team of small town
jock douchebags satanic panic is in full
swing and eddie reads an article in
newsweek about the horrors of d d
turning our kids into violent pot
smoking devil worshipers apparently this
is also the issue that came out in the
aftermath of the space shuttle
challenger disaster in january of 1986.
as he reads i was a teenage werewolf by
the cramps plays in the background when
destin calls steve to see if he can sub
to their game the phone booth he uses at
hawkins high has graffiti that reads e.t
phone home and give me head until i'm
dead the latter being a crude expression
worn on a t-shirt by the character
booger in 84's revenge of the nerds
robin and steve's friendship is still
going strong and they have an
impassioned conversation about boobies
where steve references the iconic phoebe
kate scene from fast times at ridgemont
high that happens 53 minutes and 5
seconds into the film max on the other
hand is really struggling in the
aftermath of billy's death not only is
baby girl listening to running up that
hill by kate bush on repeat she's been
seeing the school guidance counselor
miss kelly for her recurring nightmares
headaches and depression she's not the
only student seeing miss kelly for these
symptoms however cheerleader chrissy
cunningham basketball jason's girlfriend
is suffering from waking nightmares
where a monster appears to her mimicking
her mother and reinforcing her eating
disorder the same way that this creature
imitates your worst fears and deepest
trauma is drawn from several classic 80s
horror flicks it nightmare on elm street
and evil dead jonathan also has an evil
dead poster in his bedroom chrissy
shares a last name with the cunninghams
the idyllic family from happy days
chrissy's hallucinations keep getting
worse so she arranges a drug deal with
eddie but this time her waking nightmare
takes her into the upside down and face
to face with season four's big bad vekna
the way her body breaks is similar to
the body horror in the exorcist because
the boys on bikes have always used
dungeons and dragons as a lens to
process who these horrific monsters are
and what they want they dubbed this
beast becna in reference to d's most
powerful lich bekna is a name that's
been around in d d lore since the early
days in 1990 he finally made an
appearance in the vecna lives adventure
model which is the inspiration for
eddie's game as noted by vecta
exclaiming vecna lives during this scene
mike also named rob's cast thakna's
canon right-hand lieutenant that
rebelled against him in a bid for power
much like a sith apprentice would try to
overthrow their master eddie's becna
doesn't scare dustin and he pulls out
his best han solo impression to say
never tell me the odds chapter 2
vechna's curse shows the kids picking up
mike at the airport in california to
kick off the start of spring break
interestingly the date he arrives is
march 22nd 1986. the next day and we
learned that that's will's birthday in
season two so did everyone just forget
is he getting 16 candles murray actually
arrives in town at the same time he's
here to help joyce figure out her
russian ransom note the cab driver who
gives him a lift has a hulk hogan
trading card hanging in the mirror
notice that he's wearing blue shorts as
opposed to his famous red and gold
shorts that were popularized around
1986. eleven takes mike and will to
wrinkle mania the local skating rink to
have a [ __ ] in time but angela and her
friends crank up wipeout by the safaris
and pull a prank on her dragging her to
the center of the ring slinging her
around and dumping a milkshake on her
this scene evokes the same imagery as
carrie except a chocolate shake is at
least a little better than animal blood
when angela refuses to apologize elle
schmacks her in the face with a roller
skate which to be fair she kinda
deserved max awakens from another
traumatic nightmare to find the cops
swarming eddie munson's trailer across
the street interestingly although scream
didn't come out until 1996 many of the
shots and musical cues in this scene are
similar to the scene where cops and
reporters are swarming the high school
in the aftermath of casey's vicious
murder the basketball team hears the
news of her death in their party
clubhouse which used to be benny's
burgers 11 hit out in season 1. max
catches dustin up to speed while
watching courtney cox's misfits of
science where cox plays a woman with
telekinesis just like l max's lights
flickered and she saw eddie hightail it
out of there dustin knows that there's
no way eddie could have killed someone
and they decide to find him before the
cops or even the basketball team do the
hellfire stop at the video store to add
robin and steve to their quest and i'm
not gonna lie all it would take up the
entire video if i just listed out every
single vhs case inside a family video so
let's focus on the prominently featured
movies in these scenes there's a cutout
of eddie murphy from beverly hills cop a
girl rents dr zhivago there's a poster
for the man with one red shoe another
for readers of the lost ark a freddy
krueger cutout a national lampoon's
european vacation cutout a teen wolf
poster a gremlins cutout and a last
dragon poster that hints at the martial
arts shenanigans to come they actually
find reefer rick's address where eddie
is hiding by checking out his rental
history composed entirely of stoner
flicks like fast times and cheech and
chung when nancy talks dwayne munson
eddie's uncle he tells her the story of
victor creel a serial killer who
committed identical murders to these and
compares him to michael myers from
halloween when nancy's friend from the
school paper fred is killed we see vecna
plugged into his tentacley charging
station and a large creepy house in the
upside down a nod to hellraiser in
chapter three the monster and the
superhero the hellfires make some
headway nancy and robin find an article
linking creel's murders to a demon max
breaks into the guidance counselor's
office to research the other victims and
realizes she has similar symptoms to
those who died dustin references the
watergate scandal which happened during
nixon's presidential run as max searches
for the files two of the files labeled
john bonacorse and ray brown are names
of members on the stranger things
production crew when the tigers show up
to corroded corpses band practice their
garage is exploding with metal
references we've got iron maiden black
sabbath motorhead and the band's own
stick as hell poster back in california
joyce and murray leave for alaska but
even though jonathan offers to take the
kids to see police academy 3 11 pushes
mike away when he tries to talk to her
about the skate attack in her room you
can see a poster for the 1877 film for
the love of benji a retro coke clock a
flag from dynamite falls adventure golf
and the national guard's official
recruitment poster from 1972 which i
suspect used to belong to hopper along
with what looks like his old police
badge hanging on her wall before the
police show up to arrest elfer assault
jonathan and will are watching the
animated ewoks series chapter four dear
billy opens with jonathan will and mike
speaking with the agents sent to protect
them by owens jon refers to them as
panch and john the two main characters
from chips mike receives a goodbye note
from l telling him she's gone off to
become a superhero again but she signs
it from because psionic powers do not
make her exempt from acting like a
dramatic teenage girl in will's room you
can see posters for jaws in the little
shop of horrors musical and the board
game payday luckily the boys call argyle
for a ride and he shows up blasting past
the duchy by musical youth just in time
to save them from a military shootout in
their home at the sinclairs erica greets
jason at the door and confirms his
suspicions that lucas is working with
the health fire club in her room you can
see in my little pony poster and she
tells jason that if she has to keep
covering for her brother lucas is going
to owe her an nes system with duck hunt
which was released in 1984. while nancy
and robin get ready to go undercover at
the pen hearst mental hospital robin
points out that nance has a sweet tom
cruise poster top gun wasn't released
until later on in 1986 so her crush must
have come from risky business and
penhurst itself is a callback to its
mention in season one i bet she escaped
from pinterest from where the nuthouse
in curley county as well as an irl
former psychiatric facility with a
haunted history when they arrive
patients in the music room have written
their song selections on the board
including moonlight serenade by the
glenn miller orchestra red sails in the
sunset by the platters i'll see you in
my dreams by asham jones and gus khan
and wrap your troubles and dreams by
bing crosby the director of the facility
explains that music has a calming effect
on unstable minds the girls are led down
a dark hallway to victor creel's cell
evoking imagery from the silence of the
lambs and creel himself is also an
easter egg the actor who plays him is
robert englund aka freddy krueger from a
nightmare on elm street he explains that
he survived his little run-in with becna
when the song dream a little dream of me
by etta james brought him back to
reality armed with this info the two
wacky destined to tell him to play max's
favorite song and hope that it'll bring
her back to them as soon as max hears
kate bush is running up that hill a
portal opens back up to the real world
and she wrestles herself away from
vector's grasp not only does this scene
evoke similar imagery to the music video
the lyrics to the chorus say if only i
could i'd make a deal with god and get
him to swap our places and not to the
way that she wishes she would have died
instead of billy back in russia hopper
manages to escape kumchatka against all
odds fleeing to yuri's safe house at a
church near the prison seeing hopper
reunite with a container of jif peanut
butter brought tears to my eyes and so
did that banging poster of elvira
gentlemen your face is important it's
what people see on zooms and in your
passport photo you should be expending
some extra effort to keep it looking
good the fine folks at geology have some
great skin care products that you're
going to love geology is a nine-time
award-winning men's skincare company
that creates simple effective
personalized skin care products for men
click the link in this video's
description and take a 30 second quiz
tell them about your skin and their team
of dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that ships directly to your
door their products are great for
whatever you're worried about acne dark
eye circles or wrinkles they send you a
30 day trial set that's easy to
incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skin care or a seasoned
expert the gentlemen of new rockstars
are big fans of their fancy eye cream
our house might be late to pump out
content but they don't look like it
thanks to this cream geology makes it
easy to take care of your skin no need
to become an amateur dermatologist
they're offering a wild deal right now
you can get 70 off on their 30-day
five-piece trial kit head to geology.com
to get 70 off on your 30-day trial when
you use the code rockstar 70 or just
click the link below that's geology.com
promo code rockstar 70 to save 70 off on
your 30-day trial i want to see your
skin
in chapter 5 the nina project the boys
find a hidden note inside of a pen that
gives them a number to call to warn 11
that the government is after her the
number is
202-968-6161 and if you give it a ring
you can hear the same dial-up modem tone
that the boys heard will says that it
reminds him of war games a 70s techno
sci-fi thriller about a hacker who
accidentally accesses an american super
computer programmed to simulate and
execute war against the soviets eleven
is taken to a secret underground lab
although owens tries to butter her up by
telling her that the scientists there
think of her as madonna it's quickly
revealed that dr brenner aka papa is
behind all of this the scar on his face
is a reminder of the last time we saw
him encounter the demogorgon in season
one brenner and owens have built a
machine called the nina after nicolas
dalarak's 1786 opera of the same name
about a girl who loses all of her
memories after her lover dies in a duel
the nina is supposed to work by walking
11 through her childhood memories in
order to restore her lost powers and
forgive me if i say this wrong but juan
de la vienna me reviendra vidal rock
plays it plays again at the end of the
episode when l briefly gets her powers
back the duffer brothers also chose the
name nina in reference to nina kulagina
a soviet woman who claimed to have
telekinesis and her claims allegedly
started the psychic arms race launching
the us's research into psionic abilities
the orderly that l speaks to in the
rainbow room's character design is only
one black bowler hat away from matching
alexander delarge from a clockwork
orange as she's put through the ringer
with firestarter-esque challenges to her
psyche he's seemingly her only friend
inside of the lab as yuri's plane takes
off and joyce pleads for her life travel
and man by ricky nelson starts to play
in sharp juxtaposition to their bleak
snowy journey murray uses his newfound
karate skills and kicks ass midair
quoting okinawan martial artist choshin
shabana when he says his mantra my
fingers are like arrows my arms like
iron my feet like spears shyvana
developed the show in rayu fighting
style in 1928. the plane crashes but all
three survive in the wheeler's basement
you can see the game simon on the table
when nancy answers eddie's call for a
food supply drop max draws what she
remembers from the upside down and nancy
fits the pieces together to form victor
creel's house dustin points out that max
may have infiltrated vecna's mind in the
same way he infiltrated hers and
references freddy krueger's boiler room
where freddy took his victims just
before killing them when steve goes for
a flashlight at the house dustin's bag
is adorned in a slimer pin from
ghostbusters and a patch from camp
nowhere where he met susie last season
and you gotta love a kid who can quote
sherlock holmes which leads me to
believe that dustin is also a fan of
jeremy brett's tv role as the famous
detective that began airing in 84. the
hellfires figure out that the lights are
flickering in the same way that the
buyers were in season one and conclude
vecna is with them just on the other
side in homage to reservoir dogs the
tigers show up at eddie's decked out in
suits after chrissy's funeral hoping to
beat his ass for her murder the
spaghettios eddie cooked earlier betray
him and jason and patrick swim after him
as he tries to escape lover's lake on a
broken boat as the lights flicker at the
creel house vekina possesses and kills
patrick in chapter six the dive the
hellfires get a walkie from eddie who
tells them he's hiding at the local
makeout spot skull rock on their way
dustin's compass isn't working and he
realizes that this must mean that a gate
to the upside down is nearby in this app
he's wearing a 1986 crafts fury banjo
tournament shirt from vermont the gang
asks eddie to join them now that they
understand how vechna attacks and he
references lord of the rings in his
response i say you're asking me to
follow you into mordor
but uh the shire is burning
it's a mordor it is when steve is pulled
in through the gate to the upside down
the monsters that attack him are likely
sturgis mosquito bat hybrid beasts from
dnd lore in utah the boys arrive at
susie's house which is filled with her
fundamentalist brothers and sisters one
of her sisters quotes shakespeare's
henry iv as she sword fights saying you
starveling you elf skin you dried meat's
tongue this is my kind of party and i'm
guessing that this director fancies
himself a young todd browning the
director of 1931's dracula on the
timeout board you can see that susie has
one strike against her from when she
helped change dustin's grades in episode
one as the dudes explain what they need
her help with you can see that susie has
a flag from brigham young university
wizard of oz and the muppet movie a
couple of raggedy and dolls and
obviously a framed photo of jesus this
house has a whole lot of jesus the
software season's computer uses is amigo
workbench which would have been a recent
upgrade for them as it was released in
1985 she also has to explain to jonathan
what the internet is susie finds that a
call came from a computer in nevada and
prints out the coordinates in russia
hopper prepares to fight the demogorgon
as punishment for his escape attempt he
steals vodka and a lighter from one of
the guards and tells antonov that he's
going to try to scare it with fire a
tactic we learned in season two while
playing hospital grade plinko the
orderly tells 11 a rumor about a boy
called one who was more powerful than
any of the other students he was able to
unlock his powers by summoning a strong
unhappy memory and eleven uses this tip
to win a fight against her bully too
unfortunately two and his cronies
isolate l in the rainbow room shut the
cameras off and start tossing her around
the room with their minds and now i
understand why what happened at mania
was extra shitty for her and why she
felt like her boyfriend didn't
understand what she's been through
despite mike being bullied himself when
she emerges from nina she's fully
convinced that she was the one
responsible for the deaths at hawkins
lab that day chapter 7 the massacre at
hawkins lab begins with steve fighting
for his life as those sturgis deliver
like at least 20 hp of damage before
nancy robin and eddie dive in to save
him he decapitates the bat and eddie
comments that it was a metal as heck
ozzy osbourne style move i mean that was
a real aussie move you pulled back there
at nancy's upside down house they don't
find any weapons but they do find her
diary dated november 6 1983 aka the day
of the vanishing of will byers and the
day that 11 opened the gate in hawkins
she realizes that the upside down made a
copy of hawkins that day and everything
there is frozen in time at kamchatka
murray once again flawlessly
impersonates a russian comrade just like
he did in season three and they're led
to the demogorgon arena hopper staves
the monster off with fire and he and
antonov are able to escape on the other
side he greets joyce with even more love
in his eyes than when he tasted that
peanut butter back in hawkins dustin
lucas and max are being grilled by the
cops and their parents about the
hellfire club after erica makes fun of
them what is this gunsmoke the stupid
and the ugly in a sick burn referencing
the good the bad and the ugly she
demands that they fill her in as she
sips from a minute-made juice box her
questions help destin realize vecna's
true motive she raises an essential
question to establish psychic
connections with his victims in order to
tear multiple gates to the upside down
open steve realizes that he can hear the
others through the upside down so they
try to make contact by interacting with
a glittering red electric mist they
flash morse code for sos similar to the
way that will made contact with joyce
via christmas lights in season one lucas
steals holly's light bright but don't
worry teddy ruxpin and grubby will keep
her company they use it to communicate
with the others in the upside down and
dustin dubs the gate at lovers lake
watergate explaining that there are
multiple gates open at each murder site
the boys on bikes are back in action
even if two of them are girls as they
race to eddie's upside down trailer the
kids in hawkins bust open the gate and
the teens have to climb upwards in order
to drop back down into the real world
although eddie and robin make it out
safely nancy is possessed by vecna as
she climbs she falls into the swimming
pool where barb was killed and slug barb
even makes a cameo at the lab 11 is back
in her memory of the day when brenner
challenged her to crush a coke can with
her mind which we saw her flashback to
in season 1 after seeing an ad on tv
this time however she can't do it
brenner explains that she's regressing
and encourages her to go through one
final memory in order to see the full
picture of who she is as a person ella
isn't a superhero or a monster because
the world isn't black and white she's a
whole person with good and bad inside of
her l suits up in her sensory
deprivation tank suit one last time and
brenner fires up the nina with video
footage from september 8th 1979. the
orderly convinces 11 to escape and she
offers to free him from the chip in his
neck so that he can come with her the
chip is called soteria named for the
greek goddess of safety and deliverance
this is actually a hint that the chip is
what's protecting everyone else from his
dangerous powers as soon as he's freed
he attacks the guards and reveals his
double 01 tattoo to hell dun dun dun he
was one all the time
and also apparently the son of victor
creole he tells 11 his side of the story
while nancy explores the memory of his
home in the upside down one explains
that he feels that each human life is
just a weaker copy of the previous which
it turns out is exactly why 11 was born
brenner wanted to recreate one but less
powerful and easier to control which is
why he started the program his speech
actually reminds me of tyler durden's
complaint that everything is a copy of a
copy of a copy from fight club we learn
el defeated one summoning the power of
love to blast his ass into the next
dimension and open up the first gate to
the upside down he disintegrates like
the demogorgon she kills at the end of
season one and as he falls through the
sky he's shocked with red lightning that
distorts his body but even those gnarly
tentacles can't hide his double 01
tattoo and that's the last thing that we
see before we have to wait for the last
two episodes to drop i still have so
many questions like how was one formed
if the others are a copy of him what's
nancy's favorite song so that they can
get her out of the upside down and what
the hell did erica find hidden under
lucas's bed that was so gross we might
never know the answers to that last one
but hopefully these and all of our other
burning inquiries will be answered in
the final apps follow me on instagram
and twitter whitneypuppy follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you